[Music]
a fire blazes in the tinder dry forests
north of lisbon
emergency services have been battling to
keep control as a brutal heatwave
engulfs the country
we follow a team that spotted a fire
burning up over a ridge and they are
racing to stop it
planes carrying water help from above
but it's over 40 degrees celsius and
getting hotter by the hour
the problem is that as soon as the
firefighters put one blaze out another
pops up it's just too hot
and too windy here to keep it all under
control and there are families and
communities dotted about these hillsides
who are still in great danger
there are thousands of firefighters
deployed across the country
still not enough to go around for
anxious residents
we opened the gate and we saw everything
burning and i used a tractor to
extinguish the flames feliciano liberal
tells me i'm sad what can we do it's the
third time this has happened
people are being told to evacuate major
roads closed and events cancelled the
warning it will get worse
there's an extensive area that's already
burned says fire commander manuel santos
the risk is varying day by day we are
worried and working to try and minimize
the pain of the people
in the nearby town of fatima an
important place of pilgrimage for many
christians people seek sanctuary from
the sun
this plaza would normally be packed
this extraordinary heat isn't just
limited to portugal of course spain and
france are suffering too and it's
actually expected to get even hotter in
the coming days eventually impacting the
uk later this week and if it feels
anything like this for many people it
will simply be too hot to be outside
it's all being made worse by climate
change which scientists say is driving
increasingly frequent and severe weather
events including heat waves and drought
for the people of portugal and beyond a
new and dangerous reality
hannah thomas peter sky news in portugal